hey hey youtube how you doing my name is
rich Gale fun I'm co-ceo of imax
corporation those big screens and kind
of cool movies over the world and I'm
here in Davos I'm trying to figure out
different ways to make it a better place
if I have to say what's the one thing I
wish would happen in 2008 its increased
awareness about the urgency of the
environmental problem I'm one of those
guys that never gets that worked up in
the present i always think there's lots
of time to deal with something but i
have been at Greenland and I have seen
the melting of the polar ice caps story
yesterday in The Herald Tribune about
mercury poisoning and its effect on
people food stocks and what's happening
I think everybody is just human nature
kinda has a tendency to say Oh we'll get
to it tomorrow don't worry about it but
I think the kind of thing Al Gore has
been talking about just putting it up
the agenda and making sure that people
understand that the environment is in
some it's just going to be worse
tomorrow it's not going to be better and
we all really need to focus on it we
need to come together as a world and
solve the problem otherwise it you know
our legacy is going to be a barren place
thanks you too